[Music]
good morning John it's Friday you know
where I am
but the nerdfighters may have to guess
I'm wearing very expensive headphones
that's a good clue and I've got a
backdrop behind me that looks like it's
probably hello John you're in my ears
I'm videotaping myself they can't hear
you but they can hear me
yes I'm literally videotaping myself
with the video camera right now I've
decided to make a do about this for
today
yeah so we can publicize it yeah mm-hmm
it's a very fancy here there's uh well I
wouldn't call it fancy it's very wiry I
also wanted to say in this video thank
you to our 15,000 subscriber I think the
lighting here is better than in my
television studio in the basement I look
quite good I think I'm gonna come here
to tape all of my videos they don't
actually know why I'm here yet and I'm
gonna give them another clue which is
that there's a big microphone in front
my face there's an engineer which which
also helps so I think with that number
of clues you had figured out that I was
at a radio station but you don't know
which radio station I was at but it
turns out that I was at my NPR affiliate
and John was in his NPR affiliate so
that we can record an interview for the
nerdfighteria stew radio program in
existence all things considered it's
like it's like being knighted that's how
I feels it's like the nerd version of
getting knighted like NPR is the queen
of nerds and she is just like a little
excited about that at the time I may not
have seemed excited not because I was
scared out of my mind but now I'm
excited because it's over and they just
they're gonna do what they can with what
they got of us and they're gonna be
playing it tomorrow Sunday at five
o'clock in the afternoon so if it's
Sunday which is very well maybe you
should go uh turn on your radio because
it like no time at all there will be
John and I on All Things Considered
sometimes people have different All
Things Considered times based on how
your affiliate does things but it's
generally 5:00 o'clock but check your
local listings yeah we'll be putting a
link to it under Fedders comm as soon as
it's up so if you miss it it's nothing
in the world and uh welcome to anyone
who is watching this who
found us through NPR John and I are
obviously not worthy of the honor that
has been bestowed upon us but we hope
that you will accept this for what it is
coming soon there will be lots of
puppy-sized elephants more from the
Detroit Auto Show finally I will exhibit
the contents of the Tri tube and yes
there will be more from the Denver
International Airport
taking the hobbits to Isengard God God
God and I do want to say thank you to
our 15000 subscriber 15000 is not an
easy word to say hook them up and found
them and it's pretty cool there's two of
them it's Brent and Jessica youtube.com
slash Brent and Jessica there's a link
in the sidebar of course thank you very
much for being our 15,000 subscriber
understands on the size of a small city
here and John I will see you soon I
think with puppy-sized elephants